يعتبر ماء الورد في هذه الأيام شيئًا من
صيحات الجمال ، ولكنه يُستخدم لعدة
قرون ويُعتقد أنه
نشأ في ما يعرف الآن بإيران ، وهو
عنصر ثقافي أساسي هناك حتى يومنا هذا ، وهذه
القصة الكبيرة مستوحاة من Genesis
[الموسيقى]
لأفضل وردة في العالم  الماء عليك
أن تذهب إلى منطقة هيم سيدي في إيران
هناك ستجد معظم الخطيئة التي تأتي
من طابور طويل من صانعي ماء الورد ،
مرتزقة لـ mo goddamn Missouri
doxology ، Monique مدرسة من
الديموغرافيين الأسلحة معهم الذين يفعلون
توازن nimah  من الفترة غير المنتظمة
من الشهر الذي نضحك فيه في makan estes
وهناك سبب وراء قيام معظم الخطايا
بالعائلة بصنع ماء الورد هنا لعدة قرون
كتب Anishka Zoe de Tocqueville هو
شريط طاهٍ متنقل جديد وأنا آسف
ظلًا حتى الآن لديه قزحية في الظل لكن
الأولاد يظهرون  لهم تلك الظروف الخاصة
مثل درجة حرارة التربة ومستوى سطح البحر
والرياح اللطيفة تجعل الحواف
منطقتهم مثالية لزراعة الورود الكثير
من الورود حتى أنني حصلت على خلف البلدة
ولكن من  بحاجة إلى إجراء ، فسيكون كل
ذلك عبارة عن ذهب إلى عالم بيكارد من أي وقت مضى
يتم إطلاق النار على ابنه أو هدف دنيا حزين بواسطة
adidas
[موسيقى]
يتم غلي الزهور بالماء في
أواني نحاسية كبيرة حيث يتم
جمع التكثيف على موقع ebay لكل ذكر مالي من
Michigan Mobile  تعاوني حصلت
على إيقاع ذهبي أكثر رقمية يا سيدتي تامي سكادام مجاهدون لببغاء علوي
خائف من معركة واحدة
باللون الأزرق البكر هدف في فحم صاروخي
لإرفاق جانا المحمول في كيرونا ، اعتبر
كولا ميروكو تيرا سلبية فيفيان اذهب
لافاس كادمان ياماموتو جمال
هينولت الخيالي  hitch ho ho merry band of the
below messiah لديه مجموعة أخرى من
الهندسة الحتمية حيث يتحمل عدد قليل من الطلاب
الاقتصاد.
لكن بالنسبة
للبعض مثل محسن وعائلته ، فإن صنع
ماء الورد هو أكثر من مجرد عمل تجاري.
أطلق عليه اسم Akane ،
المريض الذاتي للهرمون الذي جعلني أجيب على
Ava في المحجر بعد الحرب ،
مهرجان Kiryas الذي يدور حول اشتقاق رائع من Sen
Nehru وعصير Adama beta
gulag وكل الشباب الجالبين
في العام من أجل العرض التوضيحي كرهينة
لك